[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy conmemoramos los 20 años de
uno de los eventos más trágicos en la
historia de los eeuu los atentados del
11 de septiembre de 2001
[Música]
el 11 de septiembre de 2001 fue el día
en que cerca de 3000 personas murieron
cuando aviones secuestrados fueron
estrellados contra las torres gemelas en
nueva york la sede del pentágono en
arlington virginia y un campo abierto en
pensilvania los atentados ocurrieron
durante la mañana del martes y fueron
atribuidos al grupo transnacional
yihadista de al qaeda 19 terroristas
suicidas divididos en cuatro grupos
secuestraron cuatro aviones de
aerolíneas comerciales estadounidenses
los primeros fueron el vuelo 11 de
american airlines y el vuelo 175 de
united airlines que mientras
sobrevolaban la ciudad de nueva york-
impactaron los icónicos rascacielos del
complejo financiero world trade center
conocidos como las torres gemelas
el tercer avión secuestrado el vuelo 77
de american airlines modificó su curso
para impactar la fachada oeste del
pentágono la sede del departamento de
defensa de eeuu
y un cuarto avión el vuelo 93 de united
airlines erró en su objetivo de
estrellarse contra el capitolio en
washington y cayó en un campo abierto de
pensilvania este cuarto avión no se
estrelló directamente contra el congreso
de los eeuu en washington debido a la
resistencia que impusieron pasajeros y
tripulación al enfrentarse al comando
terrorista así lo reveló la caja negra
del vuelo 93 de united airlines en un
afán de los pasajeros y de la
tripulación de correr una suerte
distinta a la de los otros vuelos de los
que ya se tenía noticia pero aunque los
enfrentamientos contra los terroristas
frustraron el objetivo del capitolio la
cabina perdió el control y se vino a
pique los cuatro aviones secuestrados
habían despegado desde los aeropuertos
de boston washington dulles y newark
tenían por destino california de manera
que sus depósitos de combustible estaban
llenos con cerca de 91 mil litros lo
suficiente para tener tiempo de maniobra
aérea según las cajas negras de los
aviones los secuestradores se hicieron
al control de los vuelos portando
navajas simples con las que a las
azafatas de vuelo y al menos a un piloto
de los cuatro aviones secuestrados y
estrellados fueron los dos primeros
boeing 767 los que causaron la mayor
cantidad de víctimas hablamos de los que
impactaron las torres gemelas aquellos
rascacielos que desde su inauguración en
1973 se habían convertido en los
edificios más altos del mundo
el horror en la zona del bajo manhattan
el corazón del distrito financiero
estadounidense había comenzado a las
ocho y cuarenta y seis de la mañana con
el impacto del primer avión en la torre
norte en dicho edificio la compañía de
seguros marsh mclennan y el banco de
inversiones cantor fitzgerald con
oficinas entre los pisos 93 y 105
perdieron de inmediato a cerca de 1000
empleados a sus 43 años y hoy con 63 el
por entonces capitán de la sexta
compañía del departamento de bomberos de
nueva york de la sección de chinatown
escuchó el estruendo mientras tomaba su
desayuno y ordenó a dos de sus unidades
salir de inmediato al rescate
justo cuando estábamos allí vi una gran
sombra negra en el suelo y luego
escuchamos una fuerte explosión vimos
pedazos de escombros en llamas cayendo
afuera no sabíamos que era eso un hombre
vino corriendo desde el exterior y dijo
un segundo avión acaba de chocar contra
la torre sur uno de los bomberos de
rescate miró hacia arriba y dijo que tal
vez no sobreviviríamos pensamos en ello
así que nos tomamos el tiempo para
estrecharnos las manos y desearnos buena
suerte es un placer conocerte espero
verte más tarde de todos aquellos tipos
de los que yo estaba rodeado cuando el
segundo avión se estrelló contra la
torre sur soy el único que sobrevivió
todos murieron
el impacto del segundo avión en la torre
sur ocurrió a las nueve y tres de la
mañana es decir 17 minutos después del
que había impactado la torre norte aún
desconociendo si las torres se
desplomarían el equipo del capitán jonas
recibió la orden de ascender por la
torre norte a través de las escaleras ya
que los ascensores estaban expuestos al
fuego para encontrar y evacuar a cuánta
gente fuera posible
así que empezamos a subir las escaleras
para llegar a la décima planta y
recuperar el aliento tomar un trago de
agua y seguir adelante
había una fila de otros bomberos y
policías subiendo las escaleras había
una fila de civiles bajando las
escaleras
de la sota éstas eran bastante estrechas
para un edificio tan grande así que
nuestros hombros se rozaban entre sí
la gente que bajaba estaba muy feliz de
vernos porque si nos veían era que había
una forma de salir y estaban escapando
de un espectáculo de horror en los pisos
superiores
nos gritaban palabras de aliento como
vayan al rescate dios los bendiga
bomberos se merecen un aumento y ese era
el espíritu en la escalera
pero mientras los bomberos ocurrían a la
cerca de 14.000 personas que se
presumían dentro de los rascacielos a
las 9 59 de la mañana la torre sur se
desplomó es decir la segunda en haber
sido impactada entretanto la torre norte
se mantenía en pie pero no por mucho
tiempo
a medida que el colapso se acercaba el
ruido se hacía más fuerte y la vibración
era más violenta
el colapso está va comprimiendo todo el
aire que había en el edificio por lo que
se generaron vientos tipo tornado en las
escaleras
un compañero salió volando por los aires
estábamos siendo golpeados por los
escombros mientras el edificio se estaba
cayendo y también teníamos ese sonido
espeluznante del acero que se retuerce a
nuestro alrededor osso ciudades y solo
esperando solo esperando que la gran
viga de un gran trozo de hormigón
viniera y nos atrapará pero para
nosotros nunca ocurrió
finalmente a las 10 y 28 de la mañana la
torre norte colapsó y se vino abajo en
el terreno aún yacía el ex capitán james
jones que había ayudado con la
evacuación de miles de personas como si
fuera obra de un milagro el capitán
sobrevivió
sabes miré hacia arriba pude ver una
pequeña franja del cielo azul y dije
chicos solía haber 106 pisos sobre
nuestras cabezas ahora veo un trozo de
cielo azul creo que estamos en la cima
del world y con la luz adicional que
estábamos hurgando y encontramos un área
en la escalera podíamos hurgar entre los
escombros y podíamos podíamos salir de
los 750 miembros del cuerpo de bomberos
de nueva york que ingresaron a las
torres y estuvieron en el momento de la
destrucción
343 perdieron la vida y más de 250
quedaron con lesiones de por vida
la inmensa montaña de escombros tras la
caída de las torres libero una
gigantesca nube de polvo que invadió el
vecindario de wallstreet en las calles
había miedo confusión llanto todo lo que
ocurría estaba siendo transmitido en
directo por las televisiones del mundo
entero una tragedia sin precedentes en
el territorio estadounidense que dejó
cerca de 3000 víctimas mortales la
mayoría de ellas en las torres gemelas
con alrededor de 2700 muertes también
murieron 125 personas dentro del
edificio del pentágono así como los 265
pasajeros de los 4 aviones estrellados
incluyendo los 19 terroristas suicidas
de al qaeda además 24 personas se
cuentan dentro de la lista de
desaparecidos y 25 mil se cifran como
heridos muchos de ellos con lesiones
permanentes
la idea de secuestrar aviones e impactar
los contra objetivos estadounidenses que
por cierto cambio para siempre las
medidas de seguridad en los vuelos del
mundo fue concebida por un paquistaní
khaled sheikh mohammed este miembro de
al-qaeda convenció al fundador y líder
de la organización osama bin-laden de
llevar a cabo los atentados contra eeuu
su principal enemigos de occidente con
la modalidad de aviones luego de ser
capturado en rawalpindi pakistán el
primero de marzo de 2003 en un trabajo
conjunto de la cia con el servicio de
inteligencia pakistaní khalid sheikh
mohammed fue llevado a prisión en
custodia estadounidense en 2006 mohamed
confesó haber sido el autor intelectual
de los atentados del 11 de septiembre en
consecuencia en 2008 fue acusado por
crímenes de guerra y asesinato masivo
por una comisión militar de eeuu para lo
cual le fue dada la sentencia de pena
capital o pena de muerte
actualmente se encuentra en la prisión
de guantánamo en la isla de cuba
aguardando por su sentencia de muerte
que habiendo sido programada para enero
de 2021 fue pospuesta por la pandemia de
coronavirus
pero que es al qaeda y cuáles han sido
sus motivaciones para encarnar una lucha
terroristas contra eeuu al qaeda fue
fundada a finales de la década de 1980
por el millonario saudita osama
bin-laden bajo una ideología
fundamentalista y una visión extrema del
islam al qaeda se conformó como una red
de apoyo logístico para los combatientes
musulmanes que habían resistido en
afganistán la invasión de la unión
soviética con los años al qaeda se
convirtió en una poderosa e influyente
organización terrorista que había
reclutado a individuos en todo el mundo
islámico y que para la década de 1990
con la disolución de la unión soviética
tenía un nuevo enemigo en la mira eeuu
los motivos el apoyo militar a israel su
ocupación militar en arabia saudita y
sus territorios sagrados y las
agresiones contra el pueblo de irak con
george bush
y sin un enemigo puntual al que
contraatacar eeuu y sus aliados
internacionales lanzaron la denominada
guerra contra el terrorismo una guerra
que estalló un mes después con la
invasión a afganistán en donde
derrocaron rápidamente a los talibanes
en el poder acusados de haber dado apoyo
y refugio a las células de al qaeda
cerca de 10 años después y tras una
exhaustiva búsqueda eeuu pudo matar a
osama bin laden tras sorprenderlo en su
escondite de pakistán y en este 2021
coincidiendo con los 20 años de los
atentados a las torres gemelas el
pentágono y el avión que cayó en
pensilvania eeuu dio por finalizada su
incursión militar en afganistán un
retiro de tropas que sorprendió el mundo
por el vertiginoso regreso al poder de
los talibanes los mismos que habían
apoyado y que apoyan a al qaeda de esta
manera llegamos al final gracias por
compartir y comentar este capítulo
especial de historia que lo encuentran
en los programas de france 24 punto com
[Música]